[Applaudissements]
avez vous que vous ne pouvez plier une
feuille de papier de format a4 que cette
fois maximum voulais essayer vouziers du
temps et que vous trouverez
accessoirement une paye de longueur de 1
km vous arriverez à la plier que
seulement 12 fois je vous rassure vous
égalerait le record du monde établi par
ghani vannes cette jeune étudiante en
mathématiques a réussi et montré durant
sa thèse
une formule qui est bien pratique qui
permet de déterminer la longueur de
feuilles qu'il faudrait épaisseur petit
e pour l'appuyer n fois par elle même ou
bien entendu ce record du monde a été
très largement surpassé notamment avec
des étudiants du hem haïti qui ont
réussi à plier 13 fois une feuille de
papier
or cela ils ont utilisé pas loin de 5 km
de longueur de feuilles de papier
rien que ça alors avec cette formule a
démontré galvan
on pourrait penser plus loin on pourrait
se demander qu'est-ce qui se passerait
si on clique par exemple 42 fois une
feuille de papier et bat en pliant 42
fois sereine même feuille de papier
l'épaisseur qu'on obtiendrait de la
feuille de papier sera supérieur à
distance terre-lune
rien que ça et encore plus fort avec 51
pliage de papier matin une épaisseur
supérieure à la distance terre-soleil
si vous ne croyez pas je vous laisserai
essayer ça chez vous et vous me direz ce
qui vous arrive est une feuille de
papier
alors avant si on a le temps je vais
vous montrer un origami qui est
impossible à le plier autrement que le
que l'organisme traditionnel organique
classique
j'espère que
programme vous convient et je vous
propose de commencer pour commencer je
vais vous raconter une histoire
d'où vient l'eau rigali l'origami de
chine et serait apparue au 6e siècle et
sera apportée par des moines bouddhistes
au japon c'est réellement au japon que
l'origami a acquis ses lettres de
noblesse l'origami du mot aux roues qui
hodie replier et du moc a mis à pied
signifie l'art du pliage de papier point
son tour est cohérent l'origami est un
art et c'est un an
les ancré dans la culture japonaise en
témoigne l'émouvante histoire
l'enfant de sadac sadako sasaki est une
enfant malheureusement mortes dû à la
deuxième guerre mondiale
suite à une leucémie deux mois après la
première bombe atomique
et ce avant même d'avoir fini de plier
mille grues en papier qui selon une
vieille légende japonaise permet
d'exaucer permet de voir exaucer son
voeu de santé de longévité s'exaucer
l'origami est un art un art technique
il en existe une foison de techniques
dont le coût sous damas le coup ce damas
est une technique particulière d'origami
qui à l'aide de petites pièces
assemblées en entre eux permet la
création de surfaces asphériques le coup
sous damas peut même être assemblés
d'une centaine de pièces
il existe aussi le froid signe par
exemple le fractal mais qui est
intéressant avec le coup c'est damas
c'est qui est le précurseur de l'origami
modulaire cette technique que je
développerai par la suite alors revenons
à l'organique classique et art
qui permet de transformer une simple
feuille de papier en un objet en trois
dimensions telles que les animaux le
traditionnel avions en papier que tout
le monde a appris à l'école à réaliser
quand il était petit et ben si vous vous
amusez à le déplier à déplier votre
origami vous obtiendrez bien sur la
feuille initial mais avec en plus des
lignes marquées des lignes brisées et ça
dans le jargon de l'organisme il s'agit
du quiz pas tord le cou à 14
c'est la signature de votre origami et
bien sûr le quiz pas tort il en existe
une infinité
il ya autant de chris patten que
d'origami pour moi
c'est ces images que vous voyez là elles
sont très particulières parce que il
sent que certaine poésie s'en dégage
comme si on était en phase de plans
architecturaux de grands monuments en
tout cas et connaissent pas tort quelque
chose de très politique
on pourrait se demander à partir
un origami quel serait le quiz pattern
qui en découlerait par exemple cette
origami du dragon pourtant on y arrive
voilà voilà le résultat il suffit juste
de le déplier et on a notre plus
patterns et on pourrait se demander l'
inverse
je m'explique est-ce qu'à partir d'un
coup et ce pattern n'importe quel chris
patten on peut obtenir un origami et ce
en ajoutant par exemple des sièges
supplémentaires au plus bas terme
initial et basse à cette question on ne
sait pas y répondre aux
on ne sait pas les mathématiciens se
sont penchés sur ce problème et ont
réussi à démontrer qu'il s'agissait là
d'un problème
np complet alors le problème np complet
qu'est ce que c'est il fait partie d'une
grande famille qui est la famille des
problèmes du millénaire alors je ne sais
pas si vous connaissez le palmier
millénaire
mais si vous arrivez à le démontrer vous
obtiendrez un million de dollars pour
quiconque réussira à le démontrer si
vous ne savez pas quoi faire de votre
dimanche après midi je vous invite très
fortement à essayer de démontrer les
problèmes d'une technologie
alors vous qui nous reste un peu de
temps et comme je voulais promis je vais
vous présenter un origami qui est
impossible à réaliser en origami
traditionnelle en origami classique pour
ça je vais vous demander d'apporter une
oeuvre
j'ai réalisé en origami modulaire
remercie les filles
alors pour ceux qui
et reconnu j d'une surface mathématiques
bien connue des mathématiciens
il s'agit d'un thor ou un donut un
beignet avec un trou si vous préférez
origami comme je vous ai dit est
impossible à réaliser en origami
classique car il est trop complexe à
réaliser avec une simple feuille de
papier
je vais vous décrire un petit peu quelle
technique j'ai utilisé pour réaliser
cette oeuvre
or il s'agit de l'origami modulaire le
rig l'origami modulaire est le cousin de
l'origami traditionnels que vous
connaissez tous il est apparenté au cou
sous damas je vous ai présenté à l'aide
de petits le petit module de petites
pièces y est de la même taille
on vient les assemblées et de proche en
proche va faire une structure en trois
dimensions plutôt complexe alors pour la
petite anecdote m'a fallu 1860 et une
pièce pour réaliser cette oeuvre là et
pour les plus matheux d'entre vous bah
vous saurez que c'est un nombre premier
voilà donc le petit clin d'oeil
mathématiques alors voilà une petite
animation pour ceux qui n'arrivent pas à
bien à le voir je vous rassure après la
conférence pour les plus curieux d'entre
vous pourrez venir la voir d'un peu plus
près alors ce qui est très intéressant
avec cette oeuvre là quelque chose qui
est apparue indépendamment de ma grimper
et que sur sa surface et ligne ou plutôt
des courbes sont apparus et ses courbes
là on les trouve bizarrement dans la
nature si on prend par exemple le
tournesol ou le coeur du tournesol et
que vous amuser à tracer les lignes ses
courbes de l'intérieur vers l'extérieur
vous remarquerez que ses courbes sont
assez similaires est étrangement
similaire comme s'il y avait un lien
profond entre la nature et l'origami
plus concrètement où on pourrait trouver
ou retrouver l'origami et concrètement à
quoi ça sert je vais essayer de vous
montrer que l'origami a une utilité dans
la vie de tous les jours est ce que vous
savez ce que c'est
non personne
en fait il s'agit de petits cristaux
formé par de longues chaînes de
molécules qu'on appelle polymères et
longue chaîne carbonée vienne s'arranger
viennent se plier en réseau pour former
ces petits cristaux
voilà c'est la forme que prennent les
longues chaînes carbonées alors un autre
exemple en restant dans le monde de
l'infiniment petit on peut voir des
grosses molécules dans la nature on
trouve énormément de grosses molécules
et ses grosses molécules
on peut les voir comme des feuilles de
papier qui n'attendent plus qu'à être
pieds et concrètement les macromolécules
par exemple cette protéine qu'il ya en
chacun d'entre nous est un laboratoire
exceptionnelle pour les biologistes en
effet comprendre la structure
comment ils se plient leur forme
complexe permet de développer d'autres
molécules qui permet de les cibler et
pourquoi pas créer de nouveaux
médicaments
encore un exemple on de l'infini
petit on peut retrouver cette forme
assez particulière qu'est le graphène
qu'est ce que le graphène le graphène
est un matériau révolutionnaire qui va
permettre d' énormes avancées et
d'augmenter les capacités de nos
appareils électriques et électroniques
en graphène là a vraiment tout ce qu'il
faut pour lui une feuille de papier et
va permettre dans le futur de voir
apparaître des objets connectés où
pleuvent modulable tels que par exemple
une tablette incurvé par exemple alors
un autre exemple alors on va passer de
l'infiniment petit à l'infiniment en
grand ou l'origami à trouver sa place
il s'agit du domaine spatial en effet
vous connaissez tous les panneaux
solaires et alimentent des satellites
mais connaissez-vous mes voiles polaire
les voiles solaires tout droit sorti de
romans de science fiction est une
solution concrète pour l'exploration
spatiale à de très très très grandes
distances à de tellement grande distance
que l'énergie solaire ne peut plus
alimentée suffisamment les panneaux
solaires ou ses voiles solaires et vous
l'aurez compris cette solution demandent
des surfaces gigantesque voile solaire
et si vous suivez bien mon raisonnement
ces voiles solaires il faut réussir à
les plier pour me mettre dans des
lanceurs et une fois dans l'espace
réussir à les déplier un vrai challenge
technique
c'est un vrai défi et vous comprendrez
que si vous n'arrivez pas à déplier ses
voiles solaires une fois dans l'espace
bah vous perdrez votre un million de
dollars que vous avez durement réussite
et a gagné en démontrant le problème est
complet alors pour ce faire 1
ingénieur japonais kohei omis aulas a
mis au point une technique de pliage qui
permettrait de résoudre ce problème
alors ce type de pillage vous l'avez
déjà tous rencontrés il s'agit d'un
pliage tout simplement de de pliage de
cartes routières tondent a déjà utilisé
des cartes routières donc vous
retrouverez cette façon de plier ses
carpes l'a donc 6 1 pour vous trouver
dans la jungle perdu et que vous
sortirez votre carte qui vous l'a dit
pire et vous repenserez à cet après midi
[Musique]
à part cette conférence
j'ai voulu vous montrer l'origami une
autre facette est à millénaire riche de
tradition est aussi riche
d'enseignements
de par ses questions qu'elle suscite de
ces innovations de l'infiniment petit
avec les molécules en passant par votre
smartphone ou encore vers l'infiniment
en grand avec l'exploration spatiale en
dehors de notre système solaire
je pense l'origami encore de beaux jours
devant lui je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]